inspired by the Curiosity rover think
science on earth is too mainstream want
to put something impressive on your
University application
well you clicked on the right video
today and I'm at the Mars yard run by
Airbus in Stevenage to learn how you can
send your own Rover to the Red Planet by
deciding to send a rover to Mars you
join an exclusive club only seven
missions have been attempted however you
wouldn't be alone the ExoMars mission is
a current collaboration between the
european space agency and Roscosmos I
asked the engineers at Airbus who are
designing and building the rover what
systems you would need in your Rover you
need to know what the mission is that's
the primary driver so in mission is to
find life we need to look under ground
to find life because the surface of Mars
is inhospitable so you need a drill the
mechanical design of your rover has to
be able to survive launch and landing
and then actually have the physical
structure where everything is stored
into that will then be able to be driven
across the surface of Mars then you need
to know where to drill how do you get to
those sites so you need to be able to
drive it in order to drive it you need
to have a computer to tell it where to
go you need to be able to communicate
with earth scene your communication
system and all of this stuff needs power
so you need to decide on a power system
as well but you can't just use any
materials in the construction of your
systems there are strict requirements
you must adhere to if you would just
start from scratch with the rover you
have to think about I've got to get this
off the surface of the planet
first and foremost so everything has to
be strong but light one of the key
constraints on us is that we can't take
organic material to Mars and that means
most plastics rubbers oils are out so
the rover's pretty much entirely
composed of carbon fiber titanium steel
and aluminium
once you've assembled all the materials
on screen you're ready to start it's
recommended that you watch all the steps
of the process before beginning your
project step one this is an allen key
insert cable x32 into female port 13
Cato's as in step 537 if the component
moves too much then this is your friend
alternatively if it's not moving enough
and you've finished your Rover however
before starting the project makes sure
you have enough funds secured to finish
it how much do you need say the current
spend for the ExoMars mission which
includes a satellite which is currently
orbiting Mars their Lander paying
engineers wages for the last decade for
prototype Rovers the facilities the
launcher the lander this is all
currently come to about 1.3 billion
euros ah so this isn't really affordable
is it no okay look you click this video
full well knowing that building your own
Mars rover and sending it to Mars wasn't
gonna happen the point of this video is
that I went and had a look at the
European ExoMars Rover which was being
built by Airbus at the Mars yard and in
the process of filming that joke intro
and interviewing the engineers there
were three really interesting bits of
science which emerged about how the
rover's designed and the science that it
does on Mars so I wanted to talk about
first up is the autonomous driving
system on the rover
it really isn't practical to design a
rover which you control remotely from
Earth because of how far away Mars is
and the fact that there's a signal delay
so any information we send to Mars
travels there at the speed of light
which may be very fast but Mars is very
very far away so when Mars is at the
furthest point from Earth it takes 20
minutes for a signal from Earth to reach
there so it's a 40 minute round-trip
delay if you want to send an instruction
to your Rover and then for you to see
the response of the rover for example
moving forwards and seeing where you are
so to get around this the engineers
designed the rover to drive itself the
rover has complete autonomy if we want
to drive it we just give it a location
on the map and we'd say drive to this
location and that can be up to 80 metres
away that's as far as it can travel in
one day the autonomous navigation starts
with the two cameras at the top of the
mast the navigation cameras they see in
3d in much the same way we do our brains
are very very good at combining images
together to produce the 3d picture of
what's in front of us we have taught our
rover to do the same thing to combine
the two images together using a
technique called asperity to look for
common features amongst the two images
that allows us to produce a 3d picture
of what's in front of the rover so we
just give it a location I'm at bakery
it's a set of coordinates with the rover
at the center and we say drive to this
coordinate and so it would scan the area
identify the location of that target and
it would drive itself there avoiding any
dangerous obstacles so it's not either
safe or even efficient to drive the
rover by remote control from the earth
and so we want the rover to be deciding
what's safe and what's not to making as
much of the decisions on board as
possible though having said that they
did allow me to drive one of the earlier
prototypes of the rover via remote
control which is done via a gamepad and
it wasn't exactly speedy
interesting with the science number to
the hardware limitations I mentioned
earlier that you're really limited in
the materials you're allowed to put in a
rover so no organic compounds like
plastics in case you contaminate the
surface and skew the scientific
experiments you also have to use stuff
that's light and strong obviously but
more than that when designing the
computer that you're putting in the
rover you're not actually allowed to use
the most recent hardware like processors
when I asked the engineer Paul why this
was he said it's because the hardware
has to be space qualified the processors
clocked at something like 71 megahertz
which is about 10 years behind the best
processes these days but the reason for
that is because it has to be space
qualified and that process does take a
long time in particular it has to be
able to withstand the radiation
environment both on the way to Mars and
on the surface of Mars because energetic
particles and radiation can cause real
real problems inside a computer and
cause for example ones to become zeros
and zeros to become one so something
that made sense is suddenly gibberish so
the rover is driving itself and doing
potentially paradigm-shifting science on
another planet using a processor that
was just about good enough to run
fallout 3 and lastly the third
interesting bit of science the weather
on Mars so this will may have been
particularly interesting to me because
I'm not a spheric scientist but
obviously when you're sending a rover
somewhere you have to bear in mind where
you're sending it so for example on Mars
the gravity is 1/3 the strength that it
is on earth so you may have thought that
the rover in all these shots looks quite
spindly in light and that's because it
only has a third the mass of the rover
that's going to go to Mars
and that's to simulate the 1/3 gravity
and that's done to more accurately
simulates the strain that the wheels are
going to be under on the terrain so they
can get a better idea of how it's gonna
drive but another Mars specific thing is
the weather on Mars and that weather has
determined a lot of how the mission is
going to operate say Mars
it does still have seasons and it does
change but it doesn't have as
complicated or weather system as we have
here the main concern we have on Mars is
dust storms Mars has a global dust storm
season which lasts for about half of the
year and it's just it's like a whiteout
but it's orange and that's the problem
for us to use
first of all you're getting this nice
abrasion happening as you'll read the
kind of sandblasted sans getting into
all your moving parts and helium most
importantly is that you have the Sun
blocked out so if you're powered by
solar power which we are and you have a
nice layer of orange dust lying across
your salary's and blocking out the Sun
because I've been yeah you then can't
generate any power so the way we get
around it is by having our mission for
the other half of the year so rather
than over design the rover and give it a
bunch of mechanical parts that could
clear dust off the solar panels the
engineers just said let's keep it simple
and the dust storms just determine the
length of the mission I should point out
that a bit of science I haven't talked
about in this video is the mission that
the rope is doing which is to find past
or present life on Mars by drilling
below the surface and the reason that I
haven't talked about that is because my
friend in ace who has just finished her
PhD she's just submitted her PhD at the
University of Oxford she's done a video
on exactly that she was on the trip with
me and so she's done a video on the
biological side of the mission so if
you're interested in that go check her
out
because she knows what she's talking
about thank you - ever for inviting me
to the Mars yard and thank you to the
Airbus engineers who were lovely hosts
great interviewees and I found the
mission an absolutely fascinating so if
you did - then there's links in the
description to the science that they're
doing and everything about the mission
and just trust me it's much cheaper and
easier to let the experts do this than
to build the rover yourself check out an
Asus video if you're interested in the
biological side of the mission that's
all from me I hope you enjoyed the video
if you did pop it alike and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]